on the borderline russian troops await
their orders misinformation abounds and
the news lens remains focused on ukraine
are they anti-semitic or just
pro-palestinian
we examine the purging of certain voices
in the german media
and thousands of miles from home and the
story they still long to cover but at
least some afghan journalists are safe
hello i'm richard gizbert and you're at
the listening post where we don't cover
the news we cover the way the news is
covered the ukraine story is a war of
nerves that still threatens to turn into
something more that word that reporters
use tensions escalate de-escalate then
escalate again this roller coaster of a
standoff between moscow and washington
is as much about messaging as it is
about military capabilities the u.s
contends russia was ready to invade and
had a false flag operation prepared to
serve as a pretext the kremlin maintains
it's still exploring diplomatic options
accusing the west of hyping the story
although the more than one hundred
thousand russian troops stationed on the
border with ukraine will have that
effect
in this information war it's advantage
moscow putin's grip on russia's media
particularly the broadcast side means he
does not face the same kind of scrutiny
domestically that his western
counterparts do and across the west
increased skepticism about politicians
and news outlets makes misinformation
some of it spread by the russian media
easier to sell however washington is
trying out some new messaging tactics of
its own our starting point this week is
the kremlin
[Music]
photo opportunities can be awkward they
can make for uncomfortable viewing take
this past monday and this gift to meme
makers everywhere
courtesy of the kremlin there was
russian president vladimir putin and his
foreign minister sergey lavrov an
alleged meeting designed to convince
audiences that russia with all those
troops piled up on its border with
ukraine was in fact trying to be
diplomatic
it looked a bit clumsy starting from the
distance they were talking at with robin
putin
pushing the americans to concessions
pushing them so that washington and the
eu would satisfy the russian conditions
discussing how the diplomacy was going
lavrov said things aren't going exactly
as we'd hoped our demands are still on
the table but they're not being met and
we see room for further diplomatic talks
but not indefinitely in order to say
well we tried diplomacy you didn't
really give in to our demands our
requests you didn't take them seriously
and so we had no choice but to escalate
there is also some stagecraft coming out
of washington the united states has
information that russia is planning to
stage fabricated attacks by ukrainian
military or intelligence forces as a
pretext for a further invasion of
ukraine including that allegation based
on american intelligence reports that
the russians were planning a false flag
operation
coming from the same u.s state
department that roughly 20 years ago
cited intelligence reports on saddam
hussein's supposed weapons of mass
destruction as evidence to justify
invading iraq now citing similar sources
when it briefs reporters on ukraine
in 2003 most of the u.s media swallowed
the lie about wmds
a despotic regime that had the intention
to develop weapons of mass destruction
had weapons of mass destruction used
weapons of mass destruction
this time around american journalists
are far more skeptical you don't have
any
any evidence to back it up other than
what you're saying the intelligence
failures that led to the iraq war loom
over everything that the intelligence
community attempts to do at this point
and i don't just mean that in sort of
the abstract
when you look at russian chinese or just
critics of the united states in general
they point specifically to the image of
colin powell sitting at the united
nations trying to make the case for wmds
in iraq i mean you see this on social
media every single time the u.s
intelligence community puts out a
statement like they did this month
they always go to the image of colin
paul in iraq so it is just
an ever-present
threat that the u.s has to deal with we
have to remember that it's not just the
iraq war there's also been a lot of
contested claims and intelligence
since then just last year and we had the
story about russia paying bounties to
the taliban to attack u.s soldiers that
ended up being unproven and military
officials said they had no evidence of
it the defense secretary today said
russia and we've had claims over this
entire ukraine crisis where u.s
officials and anonymous intelligence
officials have told journalists that a
russian invasion is imminent and those
those warnings have not materialized
the state department's move flagging the
false flag operation was preemptive
that's a departure from 2014 when russia
last invaded ukraine annexed crimea and
the u.s was caught flat-footed in a wave
of russian misinformation
tv channels beaming out of moscow played
a big part in that and remained vital to
the kremlin's message
telling their audiences that russian
speakers in ukraine are now in grave
danger and need moscow to protect
[Music]
sometimes the ukrainians and extremists
operating on the far right there make it
easy for the russian media such as when
they provide pictures of women and
children ready to defend the homeland
images taken by neo-nazi groups that are
training ukrainian militias
[Music]
there is no denying the authenticity of
the images the relevance of the story
but russian news outlets have been
giving it a disproportionate amount of
play
it's a well-known russian approach those
they don't agree with ukrainians or
americans they call them fascists but in
reality there are no grounds to say
fascists play any role in forming
ukraine's agenda
back in 2014 nobody was ready for the
flow of propaganda pouring from russian
tv channels but after eight years of de
facto war in ukraine the americans have
learned pretty well and they're finding
some antidotes for the kremlin's use of
mass media and propaganda in achieving
its objectives
what propaganda needs to do is not
necessarily convince people of things
that are not true
it needs to convince them that things
that are true are not russian propaganda
is not aimed at trying to convince
american publics to believe kremlin
talking points
it is aimed at creating confusion
mistrust
doubt and the kremlin does that quite
well i mean you look at rt and sputnik
their target is not trying to attract
audiences to russia it's trying to repel
them from the west and they're very
strategic in how they try to undermine
opposition to the kremlin's geopolitical
strategic goals
misinformation aside this is the history
russia would like the world to focus on
nato's expansion to the east
the absorption of former soviet client
states into nato began in 1990 with
german reunification and the de facto
defection of east germany to the western
alliance in 1999 poland hungary and the
czech republic each newly democratized
joined the list in 2004 another seven
countries from bulgaria in the south to
estonia in the north did the same
four more have joined nato since in
total 15 countries have effectively
changed sides bringing the western
alliance east right to russia's doorstep
throughout that period russian
hardliners were told by western
diplomats that those new democracies had
the right to choose their allegiances
but what happened in ukraine in 2014 was
hardly democratic after the elected
president viktor yanukovych tilted the
country away from nato and towards
moscow he was overthrown in a popular
uprising strongly supported in the west
and ukraine is where moscow is making
its stand
while we we shouldn't say it was an
anti-democratic revolution
uh it is true the revolution had very
prominent anti-democratic and actually
fascist elements that have deepened
their influence in the country since
now as for
nato's expansion russia does have
legitimate security concerns and it's
not just putin this has been complained
about by russian politicians for a very
very long time with the west really not
giving it that much uh a notice
let's not pretend that nato moving into
a neighboring country potentially is
some sort of benign move that russia can
ignore any more than the united states
could ignore if suddenly china started
putting troops and and weapons into
mexico the idea that this is some
imminent threat to russia
is just absolutely ludicrous as is the
idea that nato is encircling russia
right now nato countries only touch six
percent of russia's borders if you added
ukraine to that the number wouldn't be
that much higher russia's enormous
country an enormous military superpower
ukraine sought independence from the
soviet union gave up its nuclear weapons
in 1994 in order for its sovereignty to
be respected by its neighbors and russia
is the one that's violated that treaty
again
that is yet another angle treaty
violations you will not see covered on
russian television and that is the ace
that vladimir putin holds in this
information war his country produces
some quality oppositional even nobel
prize-winning journalism in print and
online but the television sector remains
firmly under the kremlin's control
doing its bidding its very best to make
putin look good even when the photo ops
do not
[Music]
to germany now and what one human rights
organization is calling an anti-arab
purge in the media there two more
journalists fired this past week after
being accused of anti-semitism flo
phillips is here with the details
starting with what happened at deutsche
welle richard
dw the state-funded broadcaster has an
arabic language arm that employed two
german-palestinian journalists zahialawi
and yasa abu malik until this past
monday when they were both fired after
an internal inquiry into anti-semitic
facebook posts some of them from long
ago here's an example from zahi alawi
what the terrorist state of israel is
doing to the palestinians is a repeated
holocaust
alawi posted that back in 2014 during
the israeli assault on gaza which killed
2
200 palestinians more than 500 of them
children
he rejects the accusation of
anti-semitism as do six colleagues at dw
arabic all of palestinian or arab origin
all fired for similar reasons all in the
last two weeks and another eight remain
under investigation
there's a pattern to the firings
right-wing pro-israeli groups dig up old
posts go after the journalists
responsible online pressuring their
employers to get rid of them
critics of these firings say some of the
anti-semitic labeling comes down to the
religion or heritage of the journalist
take nami el-hasan a prominent german
palestinian who was about to start a
high-profile tv presenting job until
far-right blogs shared footage of her
attending a pro-palestine rally seven
years earlier and the story turned into
a mainstream
the world war ii holocaust remains a
touchy subject in germany which is also
home to the largest palestinian diaspora
in the west and where german journalists
of arab descent now find themselves in a
hostile environment
thanks flo
six months ago afghanistan was topping
the global news agenda after two decades
of occupation u.s forces withdrew and in
their wake the taliban returned to power
the media's attention has since turned
elsewhere despite the fact that afghans
have so many stories that still need
reporting and they're not getting that
from their domestic news outlets the
taliban's censorship unpredictable and
often strict has not made it easy news
organizations lack the money and
resources that the job requires and
they've lost a lot of journalists who
have fled
some in fear for their lives others who
say they just cannot work under such
conditions as the international
federation of journalists puts it
afghanistan risks becoming a news desert
the listening posts meenakshi ravi now
with the story of afghan journalists and
where they find themselves six months
after the taliban takeover
[Music]
a number of us female journalists had
groups on whatsapp and facebook
messenger
i got a text in a group saying that the
taliban had entered kabul
no one ever believed that all of a
sudden kabul the capital city of
afghanistan would also be under the
control of the taliban
after the collapse of the government i
stayed in kabul for another month i
thought the situation for the media
would be all right i thought the taliban
might have really changed
unfortunately though one and a half
months after the collapse of the
government i just lost hope
it was the 8th of september 2021 less
than a month after the taliban had swept
into kabul and took power
a small group of women gathered to
protest
two journalists from the investigative
newspaper ethelat rose were covering the
demonstration when they were picked up
by taliban security
four hours later the men were released
the extent of their beating was clear
for zaki daryabi the founder and editor
of the paper it was evident afghanistan
was no longer a place for journalists
something i really was not expecting was
the kind of violence torture and beating
that happened to my colleagues i never
thought they would come out of prison in
this state
it is very hard for me to explain the
impact of losing the atellatrous office
my colleagues there and also losing the
freedom to do our work
i really can't go into
many afghan journalists who left
afghanistan after the fall of kabul
had very legitimate
reasons to
fear for their lives
given that in the past just one year
until the fall of kabul the level of
targeted killings
focused on civil society members
journalists was at the peak
so these journalists
left the country immediately a lot of
journalists left the country but still
there are many journalists still in
afghanistan and trying to work for
instance my radio radio become is one of
the last media dedicated to women that
is still working and surprisingly
taliban allowed us to keep broadcasting
but at the moment the main challenge is
not really taliban it's a lack of income
for our media that is our main struggle
this is not for only for us for all
afghans we are facing this problem so i
understand that journalists had to leave
the country
hamida aman was one of the only
journalists based in afghanistan who
agreed to speak with us
most of the others we contacted said
they didn't want the attention their
work is dangerous enough as it is
those on the outside were freer to speak
lothula najafizada was the head of tolo
news one of afghanistan's most widely
watched 24-hour news channels two
decades trillions of dollars
thousands of lives he was already
outside the country when the taliban
took over
he hasn't made it back in yet
chocofa siddiqui and zaki daryabi both
ran prominent news outlets an all woman
tv station and the atilat rose newspaper
in the weeks after kabul fell they
realized there was no way they could
stay
they fled on evacuation flights
sadiki is in canada and daryabi in the
united states
it's difficult to get exact numbers but
estimates are that over the past six
months more than 1500 afghan journalists
left the country scattering across the
globe from pakistan to albania to the
united states
among those who remain many are still
waiting to make their escape
the hemorrhaging of the afghan media
space has had a domino effect
within the first hundred days of taliban
rule more than 250 television stations
radio stations and newspapers all shut
down
that
over the uh two decades media and
afghanistan managed to find its rightful
place
it was a big achievement but it was not
an easy process
whether it was during hamid karzai's
presidency
we always had a lot of people being
targeted in the afghan media family
but now after 15th of august 2021
whatever freedom of speech was achieved
in the last two decades is really in
danger
today the situation is such that there
is no motivation to work in the media
afghanistan
it's always been very difficult to be
journalists in afghanistan and at the
moment difficulties are even more
especially for a woman journalist it's
difficult to go out to ask questions to
be in the public space but we do what we
can but again the the issue here is the
lack of finance and the lack of revenue
for us we are desperate and i tried to
knock to all doors but the response from
the international donors is so slow and
it's so bureaucratic we are in hurry and
we need desperately
to find a solution
after the government was taken over by
the taliban
all the structures of the media industry
collapsed
there is no legal support for
journalists
access has been badly limited and the
authority of the media is almost
completely lost
journalists had earned some trust in
society we were able to ask for
accountability from the government
the fall of kabul has taken all of this
from the media
total news decided
rightfully so to stay in afghanistan and
continue their work unfortunately some
of my colleagues had to leave
afghanistan after the fall but the
institution
survived
and hired new journalists but it's not
the same i can't say
it's the same afghanistan you know the
sense of fear is there but in the same
time
demonstration of bravery is also there a
lot has changed
but even if we get a much lesser number
of genuine stories coming out of
afghanistan it's better than nothing
nothing or at least very little of value
getting reported isn't an exaggerated
fear
consider what journalists in afghanistan
are up against
hey hey hey hey
calm down media workers along with
activists and dissidents are routinely
targeted and jailed
the reporting restrictions ban anything
that is quote contrary to islam many
female journalists are being kept off
the air
and yet the restrictions while strict
are also vague
nothing has been officially codified the
taliban has issued no specific media law
so no one really knows what the rules
are
in addition to all these issues is mass
poverty
food medicine and money are in
dangerously short supply and afghan
journalists attempting to report on this
are contending with cold and starvation
themselves
life in exile is easier safer
but those journalists are disconnected
from the people and stories they care
about dealing with feelings ranging from
relief to guilt
i think if i had stayed in kabul i would
have been just another person facing
severe limitations and restrictions
and i would be numb
mentally and emotionally
although it gives me some happiness to
help my colleagues get out of the
country and to be safe
i feel we are destroying everything we
built in the past ourselves
regaining the media's influence training
journalists and bringing back all the
experience that has been lost from
afghan media will take years
the future of the media in afghanistan
will be unknown until there is an
inclusive government
until life for the people of afghanistan
is not livable how can we talk about the
future of the media
many of my colleagues try to stay to
work and live in afghanistan but the
situation was impossible and they had to
leave
but not everyone can leave
and amongst those who have left they
were forced they did not do it happily
as hoshide
[Music]
and finally over the past two years
molly guinea bissau and burkina faso
have all seen attempted military coups
some more successful than others
west africa has been labeled the
continent's coup belt because of a
post-colonial history of political
instability but there is far more to the
region than that so we're leaving you
with some recommendations where to go
online outlets and specialists serving
up news on west africa that runs deeper
than juntas and regime changes
for english-speaking readers there's
west africa weekly a sub-stack
newsletter by journalist david hundayan
the conversation africa is an
independent news platform led by
academics and researchers their work
also appears on associated sites in the
uk us and france among other countries
if your focus is on francophone west
africa we'd suggest je n'athrique and
article 19.
on the podcast side it's a continent
challenges some common misconceptions
about africa and welcome to it's a
continent the podcast that decolonizes
history one story at a time
it provides historical context on
various countries including nigeria
ghana and burkina faso
finally where to go on twitter we follow
ibrahim al-bakri niye of the center for
democracy and development west africa
and amaka anku of the eurasia group
oppai adetayo is a freelance journalism
fellow at africa arguments who is also
worth tracking
we'll be keeping an eye out for west
african media stories as well and we'll
see you next time here at the listening
post
you